president biden back in washington late
sunday trying to walk back his ad-libbed
remark a day earlier in poland are you
concerned that by walking back the
president's comments
you and other administration officials
may be undermining him on the world
stage last week i told you that it was a
mistake for the white house to even send
biden to europe
if he thinks these appearances on the
world stage are somehow going to boost
him
he's got another thing coming this
entire trip to brussels was just a waste
of jet fuel
biden should have just participated over
zoom or something would have been easier
the man's incoherent enough without jet
lag
and unfortunately the angle was correct
now overseas in the midst of a
horrifying war in ukraine biden was a
human wrecking ball
when asked about reports that russia may
use chemical weapons in ukraine he said
the u.s would respond in kind
now french president macron immediately
warned against the american president
escalating things
so of course the white house had to do
their favorite dance it's called the
walk back
the united states has no intention of
using chemical weapons period under any
circumstances i will just say with
respect to any
use of weapons of mass destruction
nuclear chemical biological
russia would pay a severe price
got it an in-kind response actually just
means severe response
okay
and while visiting the troops in poland
biden seemed to casually announce a 180
degree change in policy after originally
insisting there'd be no u.s boots on the
ground in ukraine
and you're going to see when you're
there
sometimes you've been there you're going
to see you're going to see women
young people standing standing in the
middle of front of a damn tank
just saying i'm not leaving
and again his staff had to scramble a
white house spokesperson later tried to
clarify the president's remarks saying
the president has been clear we are not
sending us troops to ukraine and there
is no change in that position
but the most dangerous flub heard around
the world were his ad-libbed comments on
putin
ukraine will never be a victory for
russia we will have a different future a
brighter future rooted in democracy and
principles hope and life for god's sake
this man cannot remain power
why is he always screaming as well now
this was another instance of biden
playing pundit instead of acting like a
president
directly targeting putin plays right
into his hands boosting his propaganda
efforts back on the home front and
mother russia and making it less likely
that he'll take any off ramp even if one
appears
now reagan never said this during the
darkest days of the cold war
but biden he dismissed any diplomatic
fallout today playing cleanup man for
himself
you have more foreign policy experience
than any president who's ever held this
office understand why people would
believe you as someone commanding one of
the largest nuclear arsenals in the
world saying someone cannot remain in
power is a statement of u.s policy and
also are you concerned about propaganda
use of those remarks by the russians
no and no nobody believes we're gonna
take down i was gonna i was talking
about taking down putin i was expressing
my outrage
every time they send biden out to speak
or they build up some speech as a major
address he just digs himself and america
into a deeper hole it happens every time
today remember was supposed to be his
chance to reassure our allies after his
big speech last week but he still
couldn't get it right and things again
went sideways
do you believe what you said that putin
can't remain in power i'm not walking
anything back
the fact of the matter is i was
expressing the more outrage i felt
toward the way putin is
dealing and the actions of this man
just just
brutality i want to make it clear i
wasn't then nor am i now articulating
the policy change i was expressing the
moral outrage that i feel and i make no
apologies for it
okay
it's all getting really confusing for
joe and his team because they even had
to walk back his non-walk back
it sounded like he told us troops they
were going to ukraine you interpret the
language that way i was talking to the
troops we're talking about helping train
the troops in that are the the ukrainian
troops that are in poland that's with
the context so when you said you're
going to see when you're there you were
not intending i was referring to with
speeding with and talking with the uh
ukrainian troops that were in poland
okay this would obviously be a dangerous
escalation when reached for comment by
politico a pentagon spokesperson didn't
respond
nor did representatives for the
ukrainian government
the white house got the swiffer back out
saying there are ukrainian soldiers in
poland interacting on a regular basis
with u.s troops and that's what the
president was referring to
now this has gone from sad to scary
he is the leader of the free world he's
not an ordinary citizen kind of finding
things out as he goes or maybe he is at
this point
but this is a really sensitive situation
every word an american president utters
has global repercussions
he is simply not capable of freelancing
but nevertheless the dutiful dukes at
cnn tried their best to help in the
impossible cleanup mission
he was speaking really out of
frustration and anger clearly this is a
president who is responding with
emotions here candor is unappreciated in
diplomacy
this is a president who can very often
be candid and tell you what he's
thinking
and he's hugging children who have lost
their parents and have seen death that's
what he was reflecting
it wasn't a policy change and we're not
used to
presidents who do that
yeah gloria that's that's the concern
biden's too candid
and of course the media they weren't
alone here's the former cia director and
sec deaf
why do you think president biden made
that mistake
i i happen to
think that joe biden uh you know
his irish uh
really
has a great deal of compassion
when he sees that people are suffering
uh and i i think uh it overwhelmed him
in this
he actually said it's because biden is
irish
okay trafficking and emotionalism when
it comes to putin could make life even
more painful for the ukrainians by
giving putin an excuse to just really
ramp things up even worse than they
already been
but we got to remember this isn't the
first time joe's cleanup crew used his
empathy to excuse what was a major
diplomatic mistake president biden
directly labeled putin a quote war
criminal had something changed
administration's assessment the
president was the president's remarks
speak for themselves he was speaking
from his heart and speaking from what
he's seen on television
the inconvenient truth is even the left
knows that biden has made a gargantuan
mistake in poland now look at this
headline from salon of all places nine
words that shook the world
what was joe biden thinking
now from day one it was obvious that the
entire rationale for this trip was
political
the white house it looks like hoped that
seeing biden on the international stage
would somehow distract voters back at
home from all the economic calamities
they're facing
of course the opposite has happened
for democrats the results of the new nbc
poll are simply nightmarish
in chuck todd's own words
by a fairly large 71 to 28 percent
margin americans say they do not have a
lot of confidence in president biden's
ability to respond to this war 57
percent say we are already at war with
russia or will be within a year what's
more 68 would prefer mr biden make the
economy his top priority overall
president biden's job approval stands at
just 40 percent with 55 percent
disapproving this is his worst showing
yet in our poll since he became
president
everyone knows that if you put a
microphone in front of biden he's bound
to say anything that pops into into his
mind at the time it's always been this
way when he was obama's vp no one ever
took him seriously or what he says
seriously not even obama
and now as president
he doesn't have the self-discipline or
the mental acuity to weigh his words
more carefully
he undermines the very efforts that his
administration is making to keep europe
on our side
and we all know that the major nato
countries have no interest in forcing
regime change in russia we all know that
but biden thinks that appealing to the
press corps right in front of him is
what matters most
well of course it's not what matters
most
the white house i think keeps hoping for
its george w bush moment with the
bullhorn on all the rubble that somehow
this crisis in ukraine is going to help
his party in the midterms like it helped
republicans in 2002.
are you concerned this remark might
escalate the conflict
no i'm not
i'm not at all nato has never ever ever
ever ever ever been as strong as it is
today
never
never
now the entire problem here is that no
one inside the byte administration has a
clear strategy about what we're actually
trying to accomplish
and how to advance our interests in a
prudent and sophisticated manner
the only strategy seems to be to keep
the media happy and hope for a rally
around the flag momentum going into
november
so all their time and effort is getting
eaten up by their pr and their spin
campaign they did the same thing
remember leading up to the afghan
withdrawal and we know how that ended
they keep getting this wrong it's
actually
it's unreal to watch this when you
really sit back and think about it
the way to fix your poll numbers joe
isn't to showcase america's weakness and
get bogged down in an impossible
situation in europe
the way to fix your poll numbers is to
make america stronger
that means a domestic policy crafted by
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer and janet
yellen no no that's not the one that's
only going to deliver more misery for
more people
and unfortunately trying to clean that
up
will be left to the republicans who end
up trouncing them in the fall and in
2024
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else